and nobody saw this coming nobody
thought like the biggest broadcast show
is gonna be something that someone just
does on their own yeah look at these
Logan Paul guys like that guy just
fought he had a boxing match that was
the headline dead body
yes that guy he it was the headline of
an event the Staples Center
Wow yes he fought yes on his own live
streaming on his own whoa I bet a lot of
people watched it too I wonder how many
people watch that thing they do I mean
the zone you know what that is it's a
it's a streaming app it has all the big
major fights on it a lot of the big
boxing matches like Tyson Fury's fights
and what is Canelo Alvarez on that - I
think he is yeah there's a lot of like
top level and Ruiz to heavyweight
champion that - that's 11,000 people
watch the stream this way on this guy
gods last no hang it on to twitch or
something
no well that is hilarious
I'm trying to find the actual numbers I
haven't found 11,000 that is hilarious
what a crazy way to show a fight does he
get any extra credit for that cool it's
cool in this point yeah for sure but
like he can he get in trouble for that
yeah I mean it's he's rebroadcasting not
supposed to do that I know but this is a
whole art project I say it's [ __ ]
allowed yeah that's an inch he's making
it new enough you're not really watching
that for the actual action who do want
to see that what happened sure that
projects yeah be stealing all right
disagree artistic license kscypher
million Paul had more pay-per-view buys
and Anthony Joshua vs. Andy we see her
and holy [ __ ] had about a million or
maybe more that's a lot for a streaming
there's a lot of people coming dude
that's a lot I didn't know that they get
that many for a streaming service the
thing is so many people have these
streaming services now so many people do
it's um this says 1.2 million it did
that's a lot man well that's a lot
that's huge
oh I'm sorry the first fight did that I
just wanted more more this wait he
fought twice looking Paul the end of a
year ago yeah it was a amateur
fight that time and this is a
professional fight yeah it's
professional six-round fight and it was
the headliner of a card where Billy Joe
Saunders fight Billy Joe Saunders one of
the best fighters in the world he's an
elite fighter world champion he defended
his title on the undercard of two
YouTube guys fighting know how much of
an insult is that for him I'm sure he's
just like I'm getting paid who gives a
[ __ ] views too more abuse it's good
for him
wow that's crazy what a killer it's all
about the [ __ ] dollar nobody gives a
[ __ ] about the art do they're two
youtubers fighting yeah
there's no art right I mean there's
there's some art to it right it's a
creation there's some drama a lot of
shits going down yeah but I'm saying the
other guy's a [ __ ] Billy Joe Saunders
yeah but for him people don't know who
he is you didn't know he is right now
you do see it's like it's good so won't
know till I run by knockout he won by
knockout so it was good good showcase
for him he's a vicious he should a
challenge Logan Paul next oh he'll kill
this really I wonder of this fight he'll
make a lot more money no not the same
weight class
Billy just wanders is like 1 or 2 if
he's light heavyweight what is he is he
super middleweight Google what he is I
think yeah Billy just on his beat him
with his right arm tied behind his back
it wouldn't be fair at all it'd be
horrible but that guy is an elite world
champion boxer and Logan Paul had one
fight splint on his leg right arm tied
behind his back you know some will be
here Logan Paul someone did that
[Applause]